the Joe Rogan experience what a bang one
more up let's do it let's do it um let's
do uh smoking and drinking that seems
appropriate
yes all right DJ melody uh uh and let's
one more give it a little shoutout him
and the B junkies have a school in
Glendale California it's called beat
junkies Institute of sound they teach
kids youngsters and grown-ups how to DJ
like properly like real DJ's yeah this
is Russell Peters approves right it's a
real DJ
[Music]
upon my [ __ ] barstool Bevin on
Southern Fried Chicken all
whiskey-soaked dog is dead
and she told me last summer that she
lost her only love because it got
himself locked away he was cooking meth
trip achievements on pole stripping just
American as apple pie
now she's looking for love
that's try to die she looks little
better weather bus down for whatever and
she pop and also trick on to says she
got a few friends if you got a couple
and border
I let you [ __ ] them to all of my
[ __ ] smoke in a trinket
wasting my time where we don't think it
my whim and all whine about my [ __ ]
smoke it
wasting my time the weary and oh thank
him my women my wife
I bought the [ __ ] drinking with some
trouble to stop the sea devil
in a city jail sometimes you make
problems their own wits
as walk round bill there are lots of
unites it allows a couple fights black
their own whiskey [ __ ] I saw the whole
lot of tix [ __ ] a bunch of hot chicks
in a cover
don't make you cringe I gotta keep it
while on it I said it well done it
don't kill far by you feel I was a
cheetah's analyzed we keep a fire south
by keeping me real all my [ __ ] smell
you're wasting my time
where were you no thank you my we're
there
all my [ __ ] smell
wasted my time worryin no thank you
[Music]
I want my [ __ ] loose and Abby
pistol-grip grabby I'm a chrome-plated
Man of Steel failure
Gabriel made another like to tell it
feel
reporter so die old I love people that
be hold me down I'll be a whole lot of
friends in a killer few hands
I've been [ __ ] around Papa [ __ ]
spell came and dragged his to waste in
that time no beer no thank mo my
[ __ ] smell came in take it no
wasting my time
well me and know they can my women
[Music]
a mama [ __ ]
whoa
dude it's a great [ __ ] song man either
whitey Ford sings a whitey Ford's house
of
[Applause]